[Music]
okay
so everybody knows Michelangelo Italian
Renaissance hipster beard he's made a
few things you might have seen this
naked guy this crazy ceiling couple of
paintings but did you also know that he
is the mastermind behind one of arts
most innovative inventions
paint-by-number way back in the 1500s
Michelangelo was the man top dog he had
all the popes on speed-dial he was so
busy he used students to help him with
his work and he started pre numbering
sessions of his paintings and ceilings
so that students could follow the design
see where this is headed fast-forward to
1949 Dan Robbins was an artist at the
Palmer paint company in Michigan and he
had an idea he created painting kits and
pre numbered them like Michelangelo did
and paint-by-numbers was born pretty
soon it was hugely popular seriously
everybody was doing it for goodness
sakes J Edgar Hoover has one hanging in
the White House today Dan Robbins with
the help of the rest of us is probably
the most displayed artist in the world
sorry Michelangelo
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we all know that
the American flag has endured in its
many forms as the ultimate symbol of
freedom justice in the American Way
but did you know that our nation's flag
was designed by a high school student
from Ohio according to legend the
original American flag from 1776 was
sewn by a lady named Betsy Ross it had
13 stars in a circle representing
America's original 13 States as more
states joined the Union people kept
adding more stars to the flag
so by 1958 the US flag had a total of 48
stars for the 48 states of that time
which brings us to our high school
student Robert heft Roberts history
teacher gave his students and open-ended
assignment make a project illustrating
your interest in American history it
could be anything so Robert who was
jazzed about hearing that Alaska and
Hawaii were going to become States cut
up an old 48 state flag in his
grandparents basement and designed his
own vision for a 50 state flag when he
turned in his final assignment Roberts
teacher said anyone can make a flag and
it's got the wrong number of stars the
grade came back a B - Robert tried to
explain his idea to his teacher who
replied I'll change your gray when your
flag is accepted by the US Congress game
on Robert wrote 21 letters and called
the White House 18 times until one day
in 1960 Roberts phone rang
[Music]
hello hello Robert huh it was President
Eisenhower with news that Roberts
50-state flag design had actually been
chosen as the new official flag of the
United States the president invited
Roberts Washington where he saw his
American flag fly for the first time on
July 4th nineteen sixty cents then
Roberts 50 state flag has remained
unmatched is the quintessential symbol
of America but I know what you're
thinking whatever happened to that B -
Roberts teacher honored his promise and
changed the grade to an A
[Music]
figure one the horse this is a story
about a horse a force whose fate was
inextricably tied to the invention of
film and it all started with an innocent
question do all four of horses hooves
leave the ground at any point during a
gallop leland stanford yes the dignified
chap who founded stanford university
what thought they did all four of a
horse's hooves leave the ground
well galloping but some other academics
thought they didn't one foot is most
certainly always touching the ground so
to put the matter to rest stanford hired
a professional photographer
Eadweard Muybridge to capture the truth
on film there was a bet thousands of
dollars were at stake as well as a man's
reputation but wait cameras at the time
could not capture things moving quickly
there was no such thing as a movie
camera in 1878
so Muybridge had to get creative he
devised an ingenious solution 12 wire
triggers and 12 shutters for 12 cameras
all evenly spaced to capture a horse and
carriage on a racetrack the carriage was
driven across the trip wires setting off
all 12 cameras in less than half a
second capturing the truth you can
clearly see all four hooves have left
the ground leland stanford was right but
honestly we don't really care about the
horse what we do care about however is
moy bridges newfangled contraption used
to photograph things in motion see what
I'm getting at here Thomas Edison and
the Lumiere brothers certainly did
they took Muybridge invention
and change the course of media as we
know it creating the motion picture as
for the academics who lost the bet
they're fine
they had tender these days to be an NBA
champion you probably gonna need to be a
top three-point shooting team and who
better to talk threes then the NBA's
all-time leading 3-point shooter Ray
Allen
hi I'm Ray Allen yeah we know I already
said them our story begins on February
7th and 1945 back when all shots were
worth a mere two points that day the
Columbia University Lions were picking
on the Fordham Rams in New York City and
the NC double-a introduced the world to
the three-point shot basketball would
you never be the same again
once the NCAA permanently adopted the
triple in 1986 the three-point shot
mitigated the advantage taller stronger
players were well born with sure there
were good small players but
incentivizing shots from distance
leveled the playing field
or should I say hard with the court fast
forward 70 years and the three-point
shot is the shot and Ray Allen knows
this Ray is the most prolific
three-point shooter in NBA history for
now what the hell and Ray like all
basketball greats is a student of the
game
when did the three-point shot get
introduced to professional basketball it
all started with American basketball so
famous better known as the ABA time out
throw your non basketball fans out there
the NCAA is a National Collegiate
Athletic Association that's college
basketball the ABA
the pro league was the sort of anti NBA
until emerged the NBA in 1976 fallen the
ABA featured a flashy aversion of
basketball with a colorful ball dunks
and of course the three-point shot
and for that you can thank vent ABA
Commissioner George Mikan who wanted to
give the smaller player a chance to
score and open up the defense to make
the game more enjoyable for fans exactly
so the NBA adopted it pretty much right
away right it took a while
it wasn't until 1979 when Boston Celtics
Chris Ford my first NBA coach hit the
first 3.5 in an NBA game the first of
over 380,000 threes made in India
history you take a break from our
regularly scheduled programming to bring
you the art of the three-point shot by
mr. Walter Ray Allen jr. the key to
three-point shot is normally you are on
the floor before you get the ball nobody
likes a long do you need a great leap in
gather yourself next to me great lift
straight up and down and of course to
top it all off you need an immaculate
follow-through it's so easy anyone can
do it
[Music]
almost anyone come on Joe buddy you got
this in there you know you gave mighty
horseshoes
it's November 6th 1814 in the belgian
city of de Nantes and a modest house
built on a street that would later bear
his name
Adolphe Sax was born 28 years later
while living in Paris Sachs would invent
the saxophone and revolutionized music
in ways he couldn't imagine but this
isn't that story this is the story of
how a tough sax escaped death seven
times before mending the saxophone
hardly old enough to stand the young
Adolf fell down at three flights of
stairs stone floor broke his fall the
age of three enough swallowed a bowl of
water down sulfuric acid mistaking it
for milk years later I taught him chalk
up a bit too close to a gunpowder
explosion he was again burned when a
cast-iron frying pan was knocked over
under later a roof stone fell on his
head
living a life long scar a tough once
nearly asphyxiated and when recently
varnished items were left in his bedroom
overnight he woke up barely playing with
friends in a nearby river Adolf was
swept up in the Swift Current and nearly
drowned again he survived
[Music]
On February 7th 1894 enough died
peacefully in Paris the saxophone had
already crossed the Atlantic primed to
evolve into an icon of American jazz
music and guaranteeing sax his
immortality
[Music]